all right here with more on today's
events attorney for uh former president
Trump John lauro who's with us John
great to have you let's let's get the
good evening I'm sure you've spoken to
the thanks for being with us I'm sure
you've spoken to the president let's get
his reaction Beyond his public
statements
um we've been hearing from from one
legal scholar after another and they
think this is an incredibly weak case uh
I love Jonathan turley's line uh the
Free Speech killing indictment I wish I
thought of it
well the president is strong and
resolute he has a fight in front of him
but this is the first time that in the
history of the United States at the
justice department has weaponized and
politicized political speech the
president believes in his heart that he
had not only responsibility but the
right as any American to contest issues
in the 2020 election to raise important
facts that that the public needed to
know and and now that public policy that
advocacy is being prosecuted and it's
being prosecuted by his political
opponent who controls the justice
department and is using the tools the
sacred tools of the criminal justice
system to censor a political opponent in
the middle of an election period where
president Trump by by all polls is
leading and at the same time President
Biden is facing an unbelievable
unprecedented Scandal that goes directly
to his ability to serve in office we are
on Uncharted Terror territory we are in
a constitutional Abyss right now but one
thing about this indictment we're gonna
we're gonna take it look at it very very
carefully but IT addresses one major
issue and that's an attack on the first
amendment that should never be allowed
in this country John the the first words
of the president on Truth social how to
line in there that really struck me why
didn't they do this two years ago why
did they wait so long and he writes
because they wanted to put it right in
the middle of my campaign
um and in and he is calling this
election interference
why didn't if they felt this was a case
as serious as it they seemed to present
it to the American people why two and a
half years later why in the middle of a
campaign he's now the chief opponent of
the president Fred
yeah yep yep and I know you've read the
indictment and you've read the j6 report
they're interchangeable it's just the
same it's it's just dressed up a little
bit differently the Department of
Justice could have rubber stamped this
you know a year ago if they wanted to
but but it was it was done at a time
when we're in the middle of a political
campaign to censor one political
candidate who's getting his message out
and now the reality is that instead of
vying for votes and engaging in the kind
of discussion that we need in this
country the Biden justice department
wants president Trump to be in a
courtroom and not campaigning and I
think we know why when you look at at Mr
Biden and and the way that he um he
behaves I mean there's no no doubt that
he'd rather see President Trump fighting
this out in a courtroom than debating
him on the issues that are really
important to the American people do you
do you believe this is a form of
election interference do you believe
that they purposely delayed this
I can't speak to their motives but I do
know this that we will litigate every
issue including all of the the matters
that were raised in that indictment that
go to the 2020 election one thing that's
very interesting right now
president Trump will have subpoena power
in connection with this case so we will
have the opportunity now for the first
time in many instances to subpoena
documents to subpoena witnesses to get
to the truth as to what happened in 2020
and that's all that President Trump
wanted from day one he asked Mike Pence
pause the voting send it back to the
state so that they can recertify or or
they can do an audit but everything the
president did was with advice of counsel
and getting to the truth that should
never be Criminal
assuming that the president did not
believe this and and being able to prove
that I would say that that is Task
impossible and that is the position I
believe this indictment has put
prosecutors in uh John lauro Donald
Trump's attorney on this case thank you
sir for being with us hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else